we try to automate as much as possible
in our environment
but we often treat monitoring as an
afterthought today
i want to show you how to get started
with automating the setup of your
monitoring configuration for a new
project
using terraform this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
let's start by reviewing some basics we
need to cover two major things
what should we automate when setting up
monitoring and how we can do that
using the cloud monitoring api we can
automate three things
uptime checks which are automated
provers that can let us know if our
service is down or slow
learning policies that create incidents
and generate notifications
and dashboards that show us the state
and health of our systems
now that we know what we can automate
the next question is how
here we also have three options we can
use the api directly
we can use cloud deployment manager or
we can use an open source tool like
terraform
let's take a quick look at each of those
our first option is to use the api or
the gcloud command to create our
entities
for example you can make a call to the
uptimecheckconfigs.create method
to create a new uptime check you can use
the api explorer to determine exactly
how to make the call
our recommendation would be to use the
api directly only when no
other options are available since tools
like deployment manager and terraform
make this much easier
our second option is to use cloud
deployment manager it allows you to
specify
all the resources needed for your
application in a declarative format
using yaml files and then execute them
using the gcloud command line tool
you can also use templates to
parametrize the configuration for better
reuse
deployment manager has full support for
google cloud services and the state or
information about what's already been
deployed
is stored in the cloud our final option
is terraform
it's an open source product that allows
you to provision resources across
multiple clouds through the use of
providers
you define the resources the owner
provision and tf files
then use the terraform command line tool
to validate plan
and apply your deployment the state is
stored locally
now that we've outlined both what we can
automate and what our options for
automation are
let's take a look at a specific example
today i'm going to show you how to
create an uptime check using terraform
you'll need to start by downloading and
installing terraform to your workstation
note that if you're using cloud shell
it's installed for you you can use
terraform version to confirm next let's
create our terraform file
first we'll specify the provider we want
to use google and we'll provide a
default zone and a region for compute
resources
next we're going to define the resource
we're creating for our example
we're creating an https uptime check
against the root of the web server
on the standard https port which is 443.
next we specify the monitored resource
this is where we tell the uptime check
the host we're targeting
note that we do not provide the http or
https here we've already specified that
finally and optionally we can provide a
text string the uptime check will
validate that the content return from
the server includes that string
so that we can check availability
latency and correctness all at once
we're now ready to test and run our code
we're going to use the terraform init
plan and apply commands to make sure our
code is correct
see exactly what it's going to do and
actually create the check
first run terraform init to install the
google cloud provider
and initialize your terraform
configuration make sure you get the
confirmation message that this step was
successful
next run terraform plan to confirm that
the code is going to do what you expect
in our case it should create a single
new resource the uptime check we've
defined
finally run terraform apply to actually
create the check
note that you'll need to explicitly
confirm that you want to perform this
operation
at the end confirm that our operation
created a single new resource by looking
at the output of the command
next head to the console to see your
uptime check in the console
note that it may take a few minutes for
it to start running and returning data
let's review what we covered today we
learned that cloud monitoring allows us
to automate the creation of some common
resources using monitoring configuration
like
uptime checks alerting policies and
dashboards
we also reviewed automation options and
looked at the monitoring api
cloud deployment manager and terraform
finally we walked through a specific
example of creating an uptime check
using terraform
i hope you found this introduction to
setting up automation and treating your
monitoring as code useful
that's it for this episode come back
next time when we dive into automating
creating dashboards
this is the stackdoctor stay healthy out
there
[Music]
you